проблем навчалася в Росії 2015 року та
американські агенти
через встановлення для заявив ще на
автомобілях volkswagen та з дизельними
другові нам і встановлено програмне
забезпечення ті дозволяючи вбиті
екологічніше стандартної і йшло себе про
мільйони авто по всьому світу суду we
право джині
на майданчик всього руку міністерства
юстиції США подала цивільну позу проти
концерну за сирий підір порушено закону
про частоту повітря volkswagen у
завантажують штрафи на суму до 45
мільярдів доларів розширення претензій
дня ми столу відома прану вірус
слідування американського мін'юсту там
засуви вчше заданий надлишку в кредиторі
концерну її вважає укладу ти volkswagen
штрафом за подарунками пиві та kevin
у кримів заначок план із серії виймеш
кедровий викидень загинув позу в
розбридаються і замажемо із шоу фронтиту
Індії у не меч і не тільки банки та
інших фінн установі шоу турити позу
проти volkswagen через завдання
інвесторам надлишку технічніші проблеми
ситуацію загинула той факт, що концерн
до сенат знайшов у технічного рішення
проблемою заміни ти сун відомий софт
volkswagen може заруби ти екологічніша
шимада вагони вже встановлені на
проданих автомобілях поки не стане
удар по технологіям
автомобілі з дизельними 2у на маяки та
німецький автопром завжди за законом вал
як передову технологію на марокканському
у ринку нині ставка ти мажино музло його
теж на одному з ключових ринку в
німецькі авто в рубриці тпл
наздоженуть і японські століття давно зрубали і
ставку на гібридні технології іміджеві
у витрати вихлопні скандал негативно по
значився і на продажах на дизельних
моделей volkswagen у США вони не позбавлені
заростають а і скручуються заміжня і
американського ринку постраждала та inci
бренду концерну audi skoda та сад а
екологічні відомство США пил
пред'являєте до дизельних авто та інших
німецьких вирубних та у засіки мерседесі
в топ то через скандал із volkswagen нам
іміджу вітру тенессі у вас німецька
автопром